here's everyone Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe the conclusion so
Deadpool forces Puppet Master to make
dolls of various superheroes and super
villains and then forces them all to
kill themselves then he uses dolls of
Galactus and all the other Cosmic
entities to force them to kill each
other following this all the people who
lost their members of their family end
up hiring cast Master to go after
Deadpool but because Taskmaster can copy
the moves and even basically imitate the
person he's fighting eventually he
becomes just as crazy as Deadpool is and
because their fight takes place in the
Florida Everglades Taskmaster is
ultimately killed by man thing when he
feels fear and burns at the man thinks
touch following this man thinks since
his Deadpool's intentions realizes what
Deadpool's doing and the fact that
everybody's a fictional character so man
thing agrees with Deadpool's motivations
sacrifices his life and opens a portal
to the Multiverse where Deadpool goes
through to kill everything in existence
make sure you guys follow for more